Queen Lion of the Animal Kingdom is giving
more democracy to her citizens by adding a
legislative branch to the government.
The citizens each get one vote and are divided
into ranges. Each range will elect one representative
to send to the newly created Jungle Council.
To best understand how this system works,
lets look at a small colony where there are
just two political parties: Buffalo & Jackalope.
This colony is divided into four ranges. In
the first election Jackalope candidates win
two of them and buffalo candidates win the
rest.
All is well for several election cycles until
the Animal Kingdom Census taker comes round
and shows that the population has both moved
and grown.
To better represent the larger population
a new seat is added to the Jungle council
so the ranges' boundaries must be re-drawn.
This is where the trouble begins. Re-drawing
electoral boundaries is a huge political problem.
To help them, the representatives of the Jungle
Council hire a weaselly consultant to figure
out where the new boundaries should go.
If Weasel draws rectangular boundaries everything
is OK because the jungle council will, as
close as possible, reflect how the citizens
vote.
However, Weasel doesn't do this. Instead he
tells the Buffalo Party that, for a price,
he can turn their slim majority into a landslide
victory in the election.
With a super-majority on the Jungle Council
the Buffalo wouldn't have to listen to those
pesky Jackalope filibusters anymore, so the
Buffalo gladly pay up.
How can Weasel deliver on his promise? It's
depressingly simple: by packing together as
many jackalope voters into one range as possible
and spreading the rest of them out, The Buffalo
Party can win an additional seat without any
voters switching allegiance.
What Weasel and the Buffalo have done is called
'gerrymandering'. The intensional changing
of electoral boundaries for their benefit.
Several election cycles later the under-represented
and disgruntled Jackalope party approaches
Weasel and asks if he can manipulate the ranges
to be in their favor instead of the Buffalos'.
Indeed he can. Using the same trick, Weasel
packs Buffalo voters into a few ranges and
spreads the rest among the Jackalope supporters.
After the election the Jackalopes, who represent
a minority of the voters are now, nonetheless,
the majority party on the Jungle Council.
This is the terrible power of Gerrymandering:
Weasel can take the exact same voters and
get either party to win the election.
Unsurprisingly, Weasel's business grows and
eventually every colony in the Animal Kingdom
pays him to gerrymander their ranges.
With so many clients, Weasel now uses his
computer test hundreds of thousands of range
combinations with elaborate statistical models
of voter behavior to get the results he needs.
Queen Lion has seen what Weasel is up to and
banishes him from her kingdom. But, the census
taker reminds her that ranges still need to
be re-drawn as the population changes. So
how is it going to be decided?
Queen Lion suggests the obvious solution:
a bi-partisan committee must agree on all
new range boundaries.
This seems like a good idea. After all, if
both parties have to agree on the ranges,
then they must end up being fair to everyone.
But, after a few election cycles using this
solution, Queen Lion notices that she always
sees the same faces on the Jungle Council.
Representatives almost never get defeated
in their elections.
It turns out that the interests of the representatives
and the interests of the citizens are not
the same. Citizens want elections where the
candidates have to earn their vote. These
are close elections where either candidate
has a chance of winning.
But, representatives don't want close elections,
they want safe elections. Elections where
they run in a range that is filled with supporters.
Because the representatives are in change
of the boundaries they make the safest ranges
possible.
So, bi-partisan committees are not enough.
To truly fix gerrymandering there are three
options:
The first is to set up a politically independent
commission of appointed experts or judges
to draw the boundaries.
Independent commissions are much better than
bi-partisan committees, but still not ideal
because they usually group similar areas together
so the elections are uncompetitive.
And there is always the possibility that the
independent commission is not as independent
as it appears.
The second option is to let math decide the
boundaries. There are a number of ways to
mathematically divide an area into equally
populous ranges.
The simplest example of this is called the
'shortest split-line method'. Find the shortest
line that splits the voters in twain and repeat
as necessary until all the ranges are made.
This is much better than an 'independent'
commission, but it does have the problem of
occasionally producing skewed election results
just through pure bad luck of where the boundaries
are drawn.
But by publishing the algorithm used, all
citizens can check the results and be confident
that there is no intensional bias in the system.
The last solution is an unexpected one: hire
back the weasel and embrace gerrymandering.
But this time, pay him make the winners most
closely match the voters as a whole.
While it seems unsavory, this is actually
the best way to avoid disproportionate representation
which is, by far, the the worst problem of
gerrymandering.
But, considering these three solutions leaves
Queen Lion grumpy.
The first two are improvements, but still
may result in uncompetitive elections or disproportionate
results while the third just feels wrong.
Gerrymandering to avoid the problems of gerrymandering
is... odd.
Remembering what she learned about voting
before, she realizes all this gerrymandering
is really just a symptom of a more fundamental
problem: the method by which each citizen
gets only one vote and elects only one representative.
There are ways to eliminate gerrymandering
and restore competitive elections to make
her citizens happy, but to do that Queen Lion
is going to have to make some big, fundamental
changes to her democracy.